the nfl is drawing a line in the sand as
it tries to get more players vaccinated
in a memo yesterday the league said it
will not extend the upcoming season over
covet outbreaks among
unvaccinated players now if a game
cannot be rescheduled and is canceled
the team with the outbreak may have to
forfeit and that means
neither team gets paid for that game the
team responsible will cover any
financial losses and could face
disciplinary action also
the new york post sums it up with this
headline nfl
vax or lose raymond indeed that says it
all
yeah look i i spoke to an nfl player who
shall remain nameless
and he and his teammates have been
talking about this there there's a lot
of unhappiness in locker rooms over this
as they get ready to go back to training
camp uh
look a lot of african-american players
are saying i don't want this vaccine
now whether they're their cultural uh
blockades there
or whether it's a deeply held belief
that they shouldn't take it
that should be up to them but i think to
deny a whole team
if because remember the rule is if you
are unvaccinated and kovitz spreads
through your team
you not only forfeit the game you lose
your your seed playoff space
i mean the whole team suffers so players
are talking about this now
i think it's very complicated the nfl is
going to have to backtrack on this i i
just i just think
this is a this is a a draconian measure
and these they did not consult with the
players kaylee
yeah i don't believe in mandates by
companies by the government i believe in
personal choice i've given the reasons
why my personal choice was to get
vaccinated i believe
the vaccine created by president trump
has saved a lot of lives and i feel
confident being around the elderly now
but
the bottom line is this is punitive uh
this is not about it's
not a conversation between you and your
employer it should be between you and
your doctor but when an employer gets
involved like this
uh threatens to punish lose game take
away pay i just is over the line i think
most americans would agree with that and
abby raymond greens
brings up a great point as well which is
where is the nflpa
on this this is a heavily unionized
industry here
or league here so it's sort of
interesting that as he put it this
draconian measure
even even passed yeah well i think we're
yet to see
that as we see more players come out
against this uh because you know they
are
a very powerful organization they're the
voice for the players
and i think haley said it best this is
about i think less of a fight of getting
vaccinated in more of a fight of being
able to choose
and i bring up deandre hopkins he came
out and he said
you know he's questioning his future in
the nfl after this policy
and he cited in another tweet that he
responded to that it's because
part of the reason is because his
girlfriend's brother suffered heart
issues after getting the vaccine now
that is yet to be proven as as i'm sure
you know more investigation into that
but you can't necessarily punish players
for making the choice
to do this and it puts everyone in a bad
position especially when
you can be responsible for neither team
getting paid it's like
going to practice being being late and
then making everyone else run sprints
and sitting there and having to watch
them of course you're not getting paid
either but
it's a tough situation what if a
vaccinated player is is responsible for
the spread i mean we have seen the delta
variant move among the vaccinated
are the nfl now epidemiologists i mean
this is a this is a crazy i don't know
how you enforce this right and the the
turning point
is just the the existence of the of
covid so even though they're talking
about spreading
their it's just whether or not they test
positive and martha to the point that
abby brought up
the forfeiture non-payment clause that's
from the from old rules so we're sort of
including old rules while trying to fit
it into this new situation of covid and
then on top of it
this new policy that they have so what a
mess to say the least
what a mess and it's going to be this
way with companies with schools
universities
sports teams this is the issue for the
fall as people head back to work because
some people
you know have reasons for not wanting to
get it the other thing the only last
thing i would throw in is that they
should be doing antibody testing
um if you can prove that you have
antibodies to the virus it should be the
equivalent of getting a vaccine this is
not my opinion this is
um based on a lot of doctors that i've
spoken with who who make a very good
argument for this so that should also be
an option for these players
yeah i'll be curious to see if this
spreads to any other leagues
no pun intended with the spread all
right